well you've been doing this for the all
the time and I still say you haven't
aged well well that's on account of all
the drinking oh yeah you can drink on
the job I sure can wine I sure do where
do you how early do you get to the
houses to hide all the eggs that's for
me to know and the police never find out
there's a quick question water-rich kids
get good quality chocolate and poor kids
get [ __ ] each other why do you do that
it seems very hurtful we all have what
we're supposed to
[Applause]
[Music]
and you think this bid would work very
good issue money where you from so
during the Holocaust
[Applause]
[Laughter]
that's a fact yeah you know [ __ ] oh my -
I'm circumcised
I too am happy Yoda Easter Bunny uh do
you ever kind of do you ever eat all the
chocolate before you deliver it to the
kids I have diabetes anymore do you have
your insulin dependent yes in fact I am
I'm gonna have to take a break here to
go shoot up insulin
why do you what do you answer every
question like you're hosting a game show
from 1977 this is just how my dad was
it's learned baby seems like he was born
with a stroke
a hop skipping a stroke
[Applause]
[Music]
you wanna stick around he's gonna stick
around
let's take money in my life okay you
know I'm [ __ ] going anyway go sit on
the steps I don't give a [ __ ] if Adam
Devine as to stand bunny with me
constantly there you go you got him
there buddy
Brad Brad let's go down oh yeah it's
gonna be maybe me and you versus the
world
so Adam comes up here and he tries to
say funny things we were about them you
will say humorous things like Oh whoopee
he actually has HPV